sticking your tongue out is the ultimate
sign of rock and roll but why
this man has something to do with it
[Music]
meet John pasch he designed the most
famous tongue in history
[Music]
at the Royal College up to 1970 doing
three years as a design course there
when I was in my last year the college
got a phone call from the Stone's office
saying would a student go along and talk
to Mick Jagger about forthcoming tour I
think the tutor was quite a sort of fan
of my work so I got the gig Mick said he
wanted something related to more touring
we shared an interest in sort of 1930s
1940s tour posters particularly French
ones
that took a couple of weeks working on
the poster and brought it back to Mick
he said well I said I quite like it but
I think you can do better
and you can imagine I thought oh god
I've blown it John Drew up another
version and this time the band loved it
his poster was a Triumph and before long
another project was on the cards
they had a sort of small logo in mind
for their new record label I got a
letter and then a call asking if I'd go
and meet Mick Jagger at his house in
Shady walk so I went along there and had
a meeting with him he wanted
um something to stand alone something
like the Shell logo from the petrol
stations at the time and he showed me a
cutting that he found in the local news
agent the image was of the Indian
goddess Carly with her tongue sticking
out
and I think it was that moment that was
the real spark it represented I suppose
anti-authority it's like he's sticking
their tongue out it's rebellious kind of
fitted that the stones represented at
that time I went home and got out my
Sketchbook and pencils and tried to draw
a disembodied tongue
I did three or four different angles of
it
one of the rough designs seems to be
much better than the the rest of them
that's the one that I was going to
recommend to Mick when we had our next
meeting
now some people say to me that it was
inspired by Mick Jagger's mouth but in
fact it wasn't I always saw it as
basically a woman's mouth because I
wanted to use
um a very strong red obviously to grab
attention the tongue had its first big
debut on the inside sleeve of The
Rolling Stones Sticky Fingers album
but before long it was stamped
everywhere
these rebellious red lips became a
global icon
sometimes get emails from people that
are particularly one which some
had made his girlfriend have it tattooed
on her bottom and sent me a photograph
which I thought was going a bit too far
but um that's sort of always so
expensively
but it's obviously interesting to see
how many people wear the t-shirts when I
see somebody walking down the street and
I'm together with my wife I just give
her a nudge that's enough
to say oh yes I clocked that
foreign